hi friends it's me again i'm
getting close to christmas time you know
i was sitting up and i was thinking
about
you know how much money i spent
in my crack addiction now
to me as a normal person it didn't it
didn't really seem like that much money
but when i sat down i got to think about
the money i didn't have for my daughter
for christmas
and i don't have a car i want to get a
motorcycle and i just [ __ ] off
you know money and you know but anyway i
started out
i had a job the first job i got i got a
job at the probation department in
torrance california i
got a job at the probation department
and i wasn't really used to getting high
that much and i hated that job because i
had to sit behind the desk and do the
work and [ __ ] and
all these pretty white women right now
with the titties all hanging out i'm
looking at titties one i'm doing the
work i couldn't hit a computer
so my friend came on my house one day he
had he had to hit a tie joint
hey man let's smoke some weed before you
go to work no man i couldn't smoke a
weed
and i'll go to work man i didn't smoke
some weeping farm with the work and
there's this white girl named linda man
who they had me stacking some paperwork
in the back because i couldn't
do the handgun work and she come back
there she had this little skirt on you
know
i'm looking at her and [ __ ] i said hey
lily you wanna take a hit if you wanna
smoke some joint yeah so anyway
we went out and smoked a joint well she
had some rocks she wanted to put some
rocker in the joint we got
lunchtime she went she put the rock in
the joint very
first time i hit that [ __ ] i spent 200
[ __ ] dollars i'm not [ __ ] [ __ ]
y'all i spent
200 [ __ ] and i said what the [ __ ]
now back then i had a little just a
little bit of control
i would say i haven't had a little bit
of control because every time i was i've
always had a job you know i could get a
job because
i felt like you know my dad told me if
you don't have a job you're not a man
and all this kind of [ __ ]
but back in in the before before i know
i'm an addict now
but before i knew i was a compulsive
addict i didn't know all these things
but i know when i got paid i didn't like
going to the bank
[ __ ] that [ __ ] take my money and go to
the man getting these [ __ ] my
money
i'll put it in my pocket i'll be all
right i stopped by
for one day i had one day i had 300 in
my pocket
a friend of mine wanted to go over this
this girl's house he wanted to sit down
and
you know and do whatever they're doing
and they have some of this rock [ __ ]
whatever back in the 80s it was it was
it was real rock it wasn't that [ __ ]
it was real
cocaine i mean when you took a hit off
that [ __ ] you would want to go find you
some pennies to get in
i mean i don't give a damn what kind of
pens it was boy panty girl man you just
want to get some hands goddamn
so anyway i'll keep it real
boyfriend your girlfriend your family
pull it out let's do it
anyway so i had to have like 250 i
remember i got a ticket i had a ticket
to pay
i said i got to build you i had to go to
torrance page this guy didn't take out
down the touring [ __ ]
wagon anyway i had to go pay the ticket
and the girl said
i'm going to take a hit i said well i
got 250 dollars
i put that if you took your head off the
[ __ ] company you gave me your
head and all that [ __ ]
i said damn that was okay but i [ __ ]
off my 250
now i told myself never ever ever again
oh my god no way what no way would i
ever do that again no
not me not me i think about i started
working for gary their research
about two weeks later i got a job
through a little temporary agency i
swear for
so i got a job at gary they wanted me to
work in the store they had all these
different parts they wanted me to keep
up with which i was good because i've
always been good with numbers
spelling i can't spell but i can't even
feel my own damn name but nervous i've
always been kind of good with numbers
and they had me up in there and gary
that research and ejected devil madness
and i was i was walking away
i had a little car sports car i was
walking out of the job one day this girl
says hey man
i see you coming from compton do you
live in yeah i live in compton you know
what can you get me ride home
oh man man i'm out there and martial
whatever it is she had these
big [ __ ] dollars she was always one
of these short pants now i had a
girlfriend at home i'll tell her about
my girlfriend now i will
let me let me go back now as you go me
and robin let me do it me and robin had
got a bank account together
oh we started loading the bank account
up together now i was i mean the lady
was the lady was just as sweet you know
and i was really putting the money in
the bank and one day i decided to take a
hit i took a hit off that cocaine
next you know i'm at the [ __ ] at
theater looking at porno movies getting
my neck struck by whoever was sucking
the [ __ ] they smoking my neck
and i was phone cracking they said hey
man you got we put you out every time
you come in here you do that [ __ ] they
put me out the [ __ ] out there but
smoking crack
yeah i would do i'm gonna do that every
saturday
i'll give me fish out of the crack well
anyway i was with this girl i had
five we had five grand in the bank in
two weeks
i smoked up five thousand dollars oh my
god i don't feel good about that
anyway she came to me she said baby just
i went to
i went to the bank now my money was kind
of short
you need to tell me where my [ __ ]
money went i came up with this great
idea
i lost the car the other day and i
couldn't remember the number
so i'd stable the the the four digit
on the back they must have gotten that
money out the bank she kind of believed
me but she didn't believe it
electronics with my bad ass don't know
how they put me they put me in the two
crib
i don't remember no goddamn tools they
put me in the tuba
i knew this guy who knew my dad who got
me and he got me in the job
and i was supposed to work but anyway i
was making like a grand a week
now i was i was staying with her you're
staying crazy i was staying with her
well she liked my treat like that dicks
i mean i i could don't don't
like that dick i was thinking real good
no he would cheat
wait a minute my mother told me my
little boy she said boy she said
when you give a woman some good dick she
can't even think and i
never ever forgot that so i knew if i
could put
my feet you y'all know my mother
certainly when i i'm home
oh i'm a dicker i'm [ __ ] this lady
man she she can't see nothing
so one day when i got paid on friday we
were supposed to go out to this club and
she was she want to go out to this club
and i had about a hundred dollars i had
1200 out of my pocket and
i bought like 50 off of the crack and
she
i wanted to go out now going out to the
club just going out to the club
she comes over she she doubles back i
don't took a hit i got my point on i got
my thing in my hand i'm watching my
porno
she busting the door that's why your
dick don't get hard you're doing that
[ __ ]
um you could you imagine i'm so
embarrassed i'm sitting little pipes
still smoking them
i ain't doing them then she goes this
way
she goes she lays down on the you over
here come on baby give me some
i gotta say it when when i ain't doing
that [ __ ] i got the biggest
but if i take a hit off that [ __ ] i need
to tweet i can't i got i can't
find that that i don't know where to go
up what where i can't find that
[ __ ]
so little and she knew
but anyway we put some more money in the
bank
another five thousand bank and i [ __ ]
it off she told her mother
oh my god i feel so bad oh first of all
because the poor mother mother said
you [ __ ] you messed up my
daughter's money
you need to stay with my daughter if i
put this 45 in your mouth and blow your
god damn head off and i was like
yes ma'am i [ __ ] that up
i had the most beautiful 260z sports car
because i
i built that [ __ ]
i like to tell you i got i know what i
know i could have got 25
30 grand for that car i like to tell you
i got that kind of money
i sold that [ __ ] for a 40
rock i could hear the cars zooming
around the neighborhood
and i ain't and i ain't got no cars
around and i know
i had to call my sister to come get me
where's your car luckily
that time i got it back because the
person i was staying with knew the guy
was he called the police and the sheriff
made him give my car back
my ass went back to the same
neighborhood he wasn't there
somebody else is here no that that was
the time that was that that's that's
time i said
i got 440 for four this is the last time
i saw the car for forty dollar rock
forty night with the cochlear implant
thirty five thousand dollar car and i
could hear him doing around the hood i
never saw that car again
but i had a i had a buick
summerset regal
i let a guy use it i was living in texas
i could let a guy use it for a twenty
dollar rock
actually i know i see him at the gas and
the police pulling the seats out the car
everything out the car it's about a 25
dollar car
bam that's gone so thirty five thousand
dollar twenty thousand dollars plus it's
two five thousand dollars we hand them
up
north if i work for north i was making
let's say i make i was making 900
[ __ ] dollars a week and i was smoking
up
700 of that [ __ ] i couldn't
see that for some reason thanks to the
face of god
i can maintain like for some reason i
could i could [ __ ]
they call me a function i can function
you know i could i could kind of
keep a car and do some things but and i
always had to offer something i always
had a nice
always had a nice woman with a good job
a nice nice lady
because i was [ __ ] i know how to dick
and i know how to excuse my special on
the youtube
i know how to suck a [ __ ] [ __ ]
so i learned at a young age
that's what i was doing that did i was i
mean some women and some women do
i learned how to do it like a man a
gigolo my grandmother called my
grandmother say you
[ __ ] giggle or giggles i felt so bad
anyway i'm gonna talk about the money i
stole i stole
oh my god
my grandmother i went into purse
i took the money i went to him
but was the best thing i've ever had the
best family
and i told her i was like oh my god a
drug problem i'm so sorry for taking
your money
i'm feeling sorry and she said
i love you man i ain't worried about
that buddy i'm just glad you told me the
truth
i [ __ ] up for a couple hours
i've sold two 1500 bass guitars
this right here i never told away
somebody in my family
i just got engaged
get down another ring
i got high enough so fluffy all around
but anyway
anyway i was thinking about
all the cigarettes but
they called me cisco i drink [ __ ]
cisco wine by the
fifth like it was [ __ ] kool-aid
let me let me let me back up i started
driving a truck
and the poor people would just give me
money if i didn't have no money i didn't
have nowhere to stay i lived in a
[ __ ] truck
hey man i need 200 i would i have no
i have been all over this [ __ ]
country buying crack
they should have had me for if they had
me for i could have been meaning if they
had me for a tester the support is gonna
say let's
have you test ride i know where all the
dope spots is
and all the major cities in the whole
[ __ ] united states
and they got the universal language they
see me pull up in the truck
just like the [ __ ] this is what they
do and do that
and they already know it i'm pulling up
i'm get get your ass in the truck
i'm spinning okay
i work for i work i work for best pack
warehouse i work for best pack warehouse
for four years
i made 600 a week at hannah where to
stay
every [ __ ] week i smoked the whole
[ __ ] so let's do the math we do
but for for three years 600 a week
three years straight i [ __ ] up 69
not counting the money i was born
for the cigarettes and the wines and the
hookers
oh my god i [ __ ] around one time and
went out to that [ __ ] bunny ranch
thing they had at the goddamn what you i
got an income tax check
income taxes i had seven thousand
dollars i went to the bunny match over
there
i one got me three big old big old titty
white girl
titty white girl and the white dress was
smoking crack clock i was
and let me tell them i like to say i had
more fun i didn't get no [ __ ]
i didn't i just they just i just smoked
cracked it but didn't
the guy was outside the door he didn't
nobody he smoked all outside the door
just just let me smoke like i want to
smoke and i got to
i got so high one night i couldn't
survive and i told
i called my sister's baby i need to come
home mama i can't take this [ __ ]
she's gone get him home and put me to me
to give me give me money to get on the
bus
i smoked at him well another hundred
dollar family
going like a [ __ ] up in
[ __ ] no wonder i ain't lost my
[ __ ] mind
oh my god so when
i first got on ssi
they gave me a check for
3700
[ __ ] dollars that's what i'm
saying
i'm gonna take a couple hundred i'm
gonna sit it to the side
my mama hold this for me genie must hold
that for me mother says hold that for me
i'm not gonna come get it and god damn
me in two weeks i was knocking on
everybody's door at three o'clock in the
[ __ ] morning
give me my [ __ ] money give me
my [ __ ]
i went through that money in three
[ __ ] weeks now that's not talking
about
the alcohol the hookers and the
cigarettes that went with that [ __ ] oh
my gosh
we already we are we are already talking
about
these 2007 225 we always want to do two
and twenty now
now i got a job going cross country
that year i made 48
grand and i smoked up i know 40 of it i
know i did i
tried to handle what i knew i [ __ ] up
for i know i did and i
i just i would just and i and i would i
would get my money
and i'd pull up in the truck stop and
the little girl would get on the mic
that shouldn't be
getting them in the devil just sending
me know you know i'm already there
perfect he's seen them young girl and
then young girl that's how i was in
oklahoma city girl told me the girl told
me there was six i said baby you two you
sixteen yo
you dear that [ __ ] white girl he
pulled out there knocking on put and
over there i saw that here and that
thing i said well how much money you
need
i mean we ended with there we go again i
[ __ ] up another 600
i i was i was
[Music]
god i [ __ ] up a lot of money
god i [ __ ] up a lot of money
i got to the point i'm not
interested in i used to like you know
you know
if i cuz i like porsches man i know
every model every engine the tires are
going up i'm a porsche
fanatic and and i [ __ ] up enough to
get three [ __ ] porsches you
know
i have a baby that's 18 years old
and pretty much i ain't done [ __ ] for
him and i give her every time i see her
i give her a hundred dollars which is
once a year once every two years and i
figure that's gonna be okay that's not
[ __ ] ain't okay you don't feel okay it's
not okay
and i tell myself but see now i used to
get a social treat now i don't get no
social cheating no more
so now i got to come up with the money
to pay the rent and
most of the time i make it but i always
got to lean on my brothers and he's been
coming through
you know just but i think about i
i've been here when i first became
homeless this time
for three years straight to the math
they gave me 960 some dollars a month
i smoked up every [ __ ] and you can
handle where to stay
i would get my check i'd get a room i'd
give me a couple of white girls we smoke
up all the [ __ ] money
i did it week after week after week
after week and i kept telling myself
this week gonna be different now now
this week i'm just gonna get 120. this
week i'm just going
one dime this week i'm just going one
little hit
let me tell you about telephones oh my
god metro p says the girl down to the
place when she see me she's so happy he
gonna buy another phone i bought a phone
for two years
every [ __ ] month i pay a hundred
dollars to get a goddamn phone call and
get a hundred of the phone
everything and the next one i don't sold
the goddamn phone and i got a guess i
gotta get into the phone
you see me coming mr banks i got one for
noob
hey i i got what i knew you was coming i
got one for you oh my god the people
know me by name i'm so embarrassed i'm
looking around
they're [ __ ] people coming to
[ __ ]
but i kept telling myself that next
month you don't give me they don't give
me that they shouldn't talk me
they talked me spending three hundred
dollars on i said well i spent three
hundred dollars on the galaxy x5
whatever
i get to three hundred dollar gossip and
i know i didn't spend my money but god
damn you before the night's over the
[ __ ] want to fit in the spirit
and he gave me a 50 out of rock for the
filling all
i can't win for losing with this [ __ ]
but i'll tell you what
i ain't going to do it no [ __ ] more
goddamn me next month before that but i
got to when i get to when i when it when
the day come that they come on
the first one got there the money come
on 11 11 o'clock i'm at the liquor store
that didn't
do live liquor store he got the bottle
of brandy on the table because he know
what i want he's already up there he
know i'm going
to make them up for don't save some
money in the middle of reptiles you
gonna pull it to another person's tail
you want to pay some money bro man no
man waiting for another quarter out of
the relationship i'm going into the old
little white girl she knows she like
just sucked on my neck
she waiting on they all waiting on me
this month i'm just going to spend just
a hundred
i'm going to do it now i'm going to show
you all this time i'm just going to
spend 100.
that's it i i mean i got you y'all
are y'all knocking you y'all not going
to guess is right i'm just going
for you know the whole the two day later
the whole goddamn 900's gone
i did week after week after week
after week after week and then i stopped
to the next week and i did a week
but the thing is i'm laughing about now
because i cried but i'm not everybody
now because
it's insane but that's dead dick that's
addiction man
this [ __ ] crap and let me get
the funny thing about the [ __ ]
when you hit the [ __ ] man when you
hit that [ __ ] fight let me tell
you something y'all don't for y'all they
never did it don't ever [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] piper that [ __ ]
pipe feel
better than busting a nut in a 16 year
old girl i'm telling that [ __ ]
but after that one you don't get nothing
you know what you chasing you chasing
you chasing you chasing it
and you can't get it they're not taking
a hit and now here come the rats i'm
i'm not scared of me i'm terrified or
rat i don't know why
i take the head i get better i do they
come with rats
looking for the restaurant one time
me and a friend of mine were small crack
and she had this closet was sent to the
side and i don't know what
made that little more that little
[ __ ] come around the corner he
looked at me like yeah [ __ ] i
know you're scared of me
man i jumped up on top of that goddamn
toilet if that went that woman she
i never heard a woman she said you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you scared of a [ __ ]
man
i was i was so scared of this [ __ ]
rat dude my [ __ ] leg i couldn't
i couldn't move i mean that scared the
[ __ ] out of me oh my god
but now where i'm standing now it keeps
me from running tonight because i cuz
i'm my paranoid i ain't going to get no
brokers right
you're walking down streets over here
you see me got their rascals and running
i
ain't going off how did i get on right
anyway i just love to sit here and talk
so we we we we lick the money i spent i
mean dude i spent
god god god i know i i could've had a
house i could've had a black 911 and i
could
i could have a black gt i wanted gt i
wanted gt3 now i want a black gt3 with
custom rims on it
i wanted sitting in my damn rides with a
custom tail and the robot and all that
[ __ ] i could've
paid cash for what are they 120
i could have paid cash on their
[ __ ] and couldn't pay
cash for a house i love santa monica i
love santa monica santa monica
and i like i like i like me down the
beach in santa monica or malibu i could
get bought a house over there and had me
some little big leg white girl we could
have been kicking back you know gonna be
going to church and
you know could have borrowed a little
mercedes i like to commercial when the
guy
he says the lady buys two watches and he
will he goes on by two trucks
i got you a truck at me a truck and i
sit down i cry i'm like damn i wish i
could do that man i was
man i wish i could do that you know what
was your lady you know and
just just give her everything you know
and i you know i met this bonehead
i met this girl she's hot dude let me
tell y'all she's hot
she's she's blacker than that
[ __ ] she's black and a black
hole you ever seen a black police truck
she blacker in a police truck but she
fine i mean she but she used to tumble
tumble
that [ __ ] got laid and she and
she the way she walked
so i met her i'd take her to the house
she wanted to see the most scary movies
i've got that baby oh
no so anyway i'm trying i want to hit
let me tell you i [ __ ] that off i
bought a [ __ ]
fifa liquor oh my god took her to the
beach
accusing looking at some girl and then
we come home
she finds my crack pipe on sitting on
the counter with a rock
she said oh my god did you do that oh no
i don't you people um i would have never
came over you
my uh uh you do that
that shame the remorse
and the guilt is undescribable
i feel this [ __ ] know
she said you a nice guy man look you do
that i don't want to be
i know what y'all doing y'all get high
on that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] anything
i finally met a nice girl anyway
that's what happened so all in all here
comes christmas time
i might have i didn't have videos in my
goddamn pocket to buy serious one
i said well i was glad because we
couldn't visit nobody
on thanksgiving because i didn't had a
hundred dollars to give my family now
oh my god so that's for him
and i like to come because i i like the
people that come to me i know my friends
are there what's up y'all i know my
friends are there [ __ ] they always see
me i just met the other guy and i never
get you guys name
what's up dude what's up girl i know i
know you're there i mean
come say hi to me when you see me i got
more i got more stories
but i just i appreciate you guys
listening to me because it gives me a
chance to get off of this [ __ ]
and i hope to do to get behind the
camera ain't going to tell nobody
because i shouldn't
hope nobody don't know if y'all look
y'all hear me talk about
let me tell you what i appreciate you
about you guys you guys never
accused me you never doubt me you never
you never talk about you
you guys always give me praise because i
know i'm saying things that you guys
want to hear because you might do the
same thing
yo i'm not the only one [ __ ] i
know i know you all right yeah i see you
out there saying
except a lot of people don't like he's
telling my story a lot of people
i'm telling your story homie anyway a
lot of people come down on you because
you
had that relationship with a young girl
yeah let me tell you something
everybody got skeletons in their closet
ain't nobody in this world and never did
nothing
it's a whole lot of [ __ ] other [ __ ] i
ain't did i've been i've been what made
my buddy have me there
i'm been attending the audio because you
guys
you can process that [ __ ] however you
want to but me it showed me i got
i'm getting off that [ __ ] and it's doing
me some good stuff i just talk to
helping you so
[ __ ] y'all no no you're my friend [ __ ]
you up nah
are these talks helping you oh they
helped me feminist um
because they they okay they had me on
site net
and i don't i had one one segment had to
take three times a day
and i told i'm not i'm not i don't take
that [ __ ] anymore because
what i what i what i need i need i
needed i needed i needed
to tell the truth they told me one time
you can't poke holes in the truth
god i love the truth i don't live a lot
i love the truth you got to tell the
truth
people if you want to get some therapy
tell on yourself that's the best way
therapy it ain't what nope it got don't
worry about what nobody's thinking what
nobody gonna say
tell them yourself put your [ __ ] out
there and put your [ __ ] out there put
your [ __ ] out there on the plate and let
[ __ ] eat
everyday processes oh well you feel
better
with that i'm out
you